Okay. So Christina is calling in Christina. What happened?
Skippy? I am. So I hate being single. I hate being single.
So bad.
Today's topic. Um, we got a video here from Skippy.
I'm watching Skippy video in a minute. Someone sent me this one's unlisted.
I have been.
Looking and looking and looking to trying and to a date for the Kenny Chesney
concert, which is tonight. I've called all my ALIST friends, the,
uh, girls that I know that I find to be extremely attractive and available and
amazing. And none of them could go. <laugh> like not a single one. And.
None of them could go. None of them could go.
None of 'em could go. Maybe they were busy. Maybe they were busy.
I'm gonna just say this.
There is something very interesting about the fact that he defines them as like
very good friends.
And the first thing he defines them by is how attractive they are.
And that's how they're A-list you know,
like when I think of going somewhere with my friends,
I don't think about how attractive they are. Think of like,
who am I gonna get along with and is gonna make the experie better.
That's a good friend. How is she a good friend? I wanna bang her really bad.
Yeah. It's.
It is interesting. I I've been checking for a few weeks now. Right? Well, uh,
it's crunch time. We're at four 40,
the concerts at like seven 30 or something like that.
And I've now posted like four or five messages on Facebook.
I know that I can get an ugly girl to go with me,
so I don't want to just settle. Right. And I've had guy friends, you know,
even joke one jokingly.
<Laugh>
yo you know,
when I talk to you about the whole idea of like male and women being friends,
most of the time I'm talking about dudes like this. Yeah. I see what you,
if you're talking about dudes, like yeah, I see what you're saying. Oh, oh,
hi. Yeah.
See PO Bon it's like Mac ch you live in your mom's basement
does not a meme. You literally do. He's got a belly button collection.
Here's my poster of the Osmonds.
And over here is my belly button link collection.
Yo.
He dressed up and dragged to go with me. And that's not the point of this.
I want to go with someone that I'm attracted to. That there's a chance.
So no one that's married should be going with me guy or girl. Right.
And, um, there should be at least a chance that there's some chemistry, right.
Guy or girl. Cause now he's desperate. Cause now he's just,
you know what <laugh> you're not. Yeah. Well,
listen, dude, you're taking
and your girl thinking too, <laugh>
you imagine they get a divorce and he's hitting on both of them. Yeah.
Cause you know why not?
Okay. So let me tell you how this went down.
So there was this girl that I found online that said that she
could go, and this was at like five 30 ish or at six 30 comes around.
I call her no answer, go straight to voicemail.
I call her a second time straight to voicemail. I'm waiting.
I go online and I start looking and I even said, no, excuse me to work.
So that I on the whole of this.
And then finally I see this girl that I've had a crush on for a while. Uh,
but she's given me a, let's just be friends talk.
And so I've kind of settled into, okay. There will never be anything there.
Now get this with her. Okay. Her thing is, uh,
she asked me, uh, yeah, I can come. Um, but can I,
you don't mind if I take off a little early. So as soon as we get done,
she wants me to drop her off at the drive-in movie.
So her and her real date tonight can go to it.
But she doesn't mind pushing him back in lieu of being able to go to the
concert. So that's what's going on.
Yeah. Cause it's not a date Skippy. I'm gonna say this. She says,
it's not a date. So she's gonna go back to you and be like, you know, yeah,
let's go see this movie, whatever with still friends. So you skip,
you shouldn't take that as a date. On the other hand,
don't stay friends with people that stay friends with you just because they want
to pay. You don't do that. Don't don't do that.
It goes both ways. Some people that say that it doesn't exist.
You put yourself in a friend zone. Sure.
But if you know your same friends and that person always lingering and in the
hopes of don't think friends with that person cut the off.
But how am I gonna get my free concert tickets?
Exactly. Exactly. Exactly.
Yes. Exactly. As much as we want blame Kippy that?
No. Wait,
are you saying she's using her position of power over him to get
free stuff? No, cuz cuz she doesn't have a position of power.
He has a position of power. He has a camera,
but you don't see the power dynamics in this.
The way's the one that has the power and she's just taking free things. No,
he has the power. She cannot have the power. Okay. Okay.
Why would she have the power? How could she have the power? Uh,
I just thought that sometimes attractive women have power over the no they
don't. Okay. Ever it's just okay. No. Is she a man?
So now what I'm going to do is I'm going.
Sorry. I'm on some pity today. I know me too. Is you man? No,
can't happen. Petty petty.
Girl that I was supposed to go on a date with and uh,
leave a voice message and tell her what I think of her.
Um, and maybe we'll even get a chance to, uh,
talk to her on the phone but out it. So
Here we go.
Hi, leave a call back number.
Hi Christina. It's uh, Skippy. And you'll notice that on Facebook.
I deleted you as a friend because I think that you were a giant
by.
Okay.
I agree with the floor. I agree with the floor.
The floor is right on that one. Good job. Yeah. I agree with you. Yeah. I,
everything you said floor, everything you said, I feel like toxic is the,
is the only, I don't know. I don't know. You know what's crazy though. You know,
it's crazy. You see this in movies. Sometimes people get voice message.
You hear about stuff like this. Me personally, I've never heard it cuz again,
I'm not a woman and I don't, you know, they don't send me,
but I've had people tell me that these kinds of things happen. Um,
it's just wild to hear someone just say like you, all this other stuff.
Like someone rejects, you just move on with your day, you know?
And you set up everything to get rejected as also like,
yeah guys, this is exactly how you don't take a rejection.
If someone stands you up, they're not that into you.
If someone responds to something you said, and they're like, yeah,
I'll be there. And then they lie.
And they're not that into you pay people who are into you are gonna make an
effort. So when you take this and you take this huge like blow,
when you feel the needs are like, get back at them, you don't look good.
You make yourself look dumber. They're not that into you.
And you only look more desperate and angry.
And that energy that you give off is gonna push more people away.
That resentful thing. Super weak. So yeah, on this part, man,
Skipp me be doing some crazy stuff like beta and don't think it's just him.
There's a lot of other people who do stuff like this. That's.
Beta right there by going to sleep and then not waking.
And I get the accidents happen. Don't get me wrong. And that might even be,
Nope. That's not you calling in someone else. Um, but I get that.
You were trying to, uh, uh.
You imagine if it was her calling, it's like, Hey, keep you, sorry.
I just woke up, but I'm ready. I'm just getting dressed right now. Okay, cool.
I'll see you in like 20 minutes and she hangs up, she hits the voice message.
She hears that <laugh>.
You were gonna take a nap or something like that. Anyway.
So my whole deal is this phone call is to tell you that you're a.
And I really don't wanna talk to you again. Even if you have a great excuse,
you promise. I was pretty mean with that. Right. But I'm.
That should not happen. And now I guess, yeah, now I'm a big Dick, but uh,
I don't know. I don't know. I'm a really bitter kid right now.
I hate.
Right now. Right now only,
Hey man, if you see yourself in any of this behavior, yeah.
Just try to correct it. Listen at the end of the day,
it's not like I sit here and I want terrible things for Skippy or anybody else.
Like, you know,
there are certain behaviors that you engage in that will contribute to your own
demise.
And I think it's important for us to recognize that that stuff hurts the people
around us and hurts us ourselves. So there is some responsibility to be better.
Um, when I watch skip you doing this stuff, I'm just like, bro,
can't be doing that. I.
Hate being single. I hate being single so bad. The only,
the only reason why I'm like why I don't just like lower my standards and
go out with and go after like a girl that I'm not attracted to at all or,
um, change my standards and go for a girl that, uh,
would probably go out with me.
But isn't anywhere near what I can say or my type.
The only reason that I do all that is because I have the hope that on the
horizon that there's something better. Right? So you just like go, okay,
this is just a phase I'm going through. Well,
this phase has been going on for 33 years.
Okay. Now the first, you know, 16 shouldn't count, but okay.
So 17 years of my life has just been okay in two years for
a Mormon mission.
Do you expect me to have sympathy for you?
Is that what I'm supposed to 17 years lower your standards?
What do you want me to tell you lower your standards? I would say this to women.
I would say this to you as well.
It's like if you go onto the dating world and the people you keep trying to go
afterwards are not interested. You it's either one or two things. All right.
Either your standards are too high. Okay? If it's 17 years worth of rejection,
either your standards are way too high. Okay?
And you need to humble yourself or two. The problem is your behavior.
When you engage in these relationships and you need to humble yourself and look
at your own behavior. So one of those two things we're like, oh, dating sucks.
No, you suck. You are the problem.
Because at the end of the day, if it's been 17 years, 17 years,
and it's been consistent that you've been having the same results for 17 years.
The common denominator is you.
You are the common denominator in all of those situations.
So you have to change your behavior. I don't know how to say it to you,
but it is, is what it is. Okay. And it doesn't matter how long it's been going.
17 years. I, I don't care. I've been, I've been, uh,
going to the bathroom and taking dumps for 38 years.
Mm I'm planning on doing that for a couple of other years. Still.
That's gonna come outta my. Don't matter how long you do it.
It's what you do.
If you were on the job market and you were applying to a bunch of jobs for 17
years and got rejected every time I want to get a job that pays me 20,
and none of them hired you.
Maybe you gotta take a job that only pays $15 an hour.
That's what we would tell you as grown adults.
There's nobody who would feel sympathy for you.
If you were constantly looking for that job and you never got it.
So why would you think it's any different from the marketplace?
It's because people have this arrogant view that they deserve somebody mm-hmm
<affirmative> you don't deserve anything.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> you're not owed anything in this world.
You just get what you get mm-hmm <affirmative> so either put in the work or stop
crying and its, its that job, that job that you're applying for,
you have to check is your resume. Good? Yep. You have the good credentials. Yep.
Are you, how do you go to or even applying? Are you, how are you applying?
Are you even applying mom talking about,
I wish I could win the lottery and you never buy a ticket. Boo.
You don't even have to play that game.
For a Mormon. So what's that 15 years,
15 years of my life of horrible luck with the ladies, you know,
I have a gun. Okay. So Christina is calling in.
So that's what you call me, Christina. What happened?
I am so, so sorry. Um,
my phone died. Planning on going with you. I did not. I was dead. Like
I really am sick.
Like I I've been doing with these sick issues all week and then
killing myself physically and I I'm sick.
I'm head. I was gonna go to a concert with you. I,
I think it'll be fun to talk to you and no, you have a great personality.
I wasn't going the concert. Cause I was excited to go to the concert, honestly,
dark light. I kinda had a headache of migraine, dark white movies.
Cool setting sounded great, but do want, I'll go. Um,
and then I'm an a D D and it's even worse when I'm tired.
I get distracted and things like this happen. I can understand how you be upset,
but I think that's a little bit it's immature of you too so that
you hear that or recording. Okay. What you wants do um.
<Laugh> well, Hey, uh, my date just got here, so I'm gonna hang up, but uh,
take care and uh, yeah,
th this is the girl I was supposed to go with. Okay. Uh, take care. Bye.
You thought you were petty.
You thought you were petty and Dan let's keep you went. Hold my beer.
Hold my Mar margarita. Hold my sangria. How about to take you to Petton
won't you take me too.
Remember? Watching recess. Remember watching recess in the snitch. Yeah.
And you'd get a wedge every now and then. And you'd be like, yeah, good.
There are certain kids. You just look at man, come up, throw him over the,
when the kid been a little all day. Yeah. And then he falls ground. Yeah.
And you're like, yeah, yeah. You bump your head. That's rights. What you get?
This is what I mean, you bring that as energy onto your next tape.
This woman walks in. She's like, yeah, what's wrong with this bro? And you know,
the worst part is like, when you leave all these experiences on a bad term,
you know, word gets around. People talk. Oh,
so you ruin the rest of your dating pool as well, guys, like I said,
when you take a actually we put,
he did another video on another guy who gets rejected. Take it like him.
Walk away as best as you can take a Al take kit, hold it high. Be like,
you know what? That's mine. That's right. And then maybe keep moving,
keep moving. And then may, if you catch a second one,
you're gonna turn it around and make it to w that's it. That's it.
Chad Skippy needs to meet Chad. Yup. Yo Skippy needs to meet. Yep.
Remember Chad? Yep. Yep. Whenever the girl was trying to play and he was like,
right, cool. Whatever. Yeah. And he went with it. Yeah. Like,
and I'm sure Chad got a bunch of DMS after that. Definitely guaranteed.
Guaranteed. You want to advertise yourself? That's one good way to do it.
Take the L like a champ. You took it. And that's not even a dating thing.
That's a everything. Life, everyday life thing. Like you go to a job,
you know what I mean? You, you go for an interview. They reject you.
Don't walk out. Cury everybody and getting mad cuz you didn't get the job.
I didn't want that job anyway. Cause guess what?
They might call you back in the future to hire you.
That's happened numerous times. Guess what?
When you off that recruiter who happens to be the one who recruits there. Well,
that recruiter sometimes has to recruit for other companies.
So it might come back to bite. You then walk away. So clean, you know,
she was generous with her excuse and she was what's kinder than I would've been.
And someone left me the kind of toxic stuff that he did. Yeah. Um, but yeah,
maybe she also did. So for her own safety, who knows. Yeah.
And she says you're immature, but that, yeah, you don't, you don't know you.
Cause the way he acting that is immature.
Okay. Sorry.
It's really tough to hang on a person and drive and,
and video and video all at the same time. Yeah. I know. What's offing.
Yeah. I decided to uh, videotape the adventure of uh, today.
Okay. But yeah. All right, let's go do it.
It was like when you're in the club and so want ask again here, my name's Lisa
huh? Lisa and a little bit of slop comes out and hits you on the side.
Me. I always like looking at people, talking to the club.
Cause sometimes you see one person being like this. Yeah.
And the other person leading this and they just keep bleeding like this and
pushing on this shoulder right here.
And the person's really trying to get away and you're like, no at it, Lisa,
I like grinding on you without your consent for 30 seconds.
Can I buy you a drink? Huh? Can I buy you a drink? <laugh>
you know what the best parts about going to close?
Cause sometimes last call comes around and then last call passes and they turn
on the lights. Yeah. And you see the girl you were dancing with you like who?
God, oh, you look different with sweat and all this other stuff coming down.
Diff diff you smell different too. Hmm.
That diff <laugh> definitely.
And so now she's about to get out of my car and leave for date number two.
And he apparently did not know that you were,
you were on one date going to a number and that's why she was late. So, uh,
have fun telling him about that. Thanks for coming with me.
I know now that he is there watching us, right? Yeah.
Now he's paying for her though. We're watching him for her. Uh,
she doesn't want me video creeping him, but let's see that's you can't no,
you can't see his face. There's so there he is praying for that.
Are we done bro?
My hand is an imprint of my face because I face Palm so much.
My mans is bugging.
My man slapped the own chest city belt on his penis. I never heard of that.
I ain, never heard a man slapping, no Chasity belt on the penis.
He then swallowed the key. No, he didn't even swallow it, man. He, he, he
cause swallow. It means he has a chance to it out and dig it back out.
My man made that disappear. There's no way he coming out of the,
the Virgin realm, the show realm. Virgin realm. Okay.
So that's the end of uh, date number one for you.
And you're on to date number two and I'm onto a drive home.
I'm onto Kenny Chesney. <laugh> yeah. Yep. Cause I, cause I of course was Billy.
Uh, Karen.
Let's go. Not much left. Let's get this done last,
last mile. That stretch. All right.
Um, put her there, although Billy Carrington is pretty hot,
even though he's just the opening act. Yeah. Right. Well he's no Kenny yet.
I didn't know who he was. And I was like, he's pretty attractive, you know?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Well, uh, good luck. Good luck with Kenny. Okay. Thanks.
Here's the thing though. I wanna point this out. If,
if Anella had made any effort to have
been cute and flirty and everything like that. Now, granted,
I know that she wants to just be friends and I get that.
The nice thing was I was able to stare at hot girls while I was on a date with
her. So that was nice. I mean like really I was able to, like,
there was a girl in front of us that had great butt and I didn't feel bad at all
for looking at, at that girl's butt. Um,
because she was not my date. Really. She was just a friend anyways.
But if she had made a small effort, uh,
to have been a little bit flirty or something like that, then um,
she would've gotten this and, and I'm going to turn it on. Oh, oh,
check that out. Cuz I bought one for me and one potentially for her,
but Anella you treated me too much like a guy friend.
It wasn't really a date.
It was me hanging out with a person that happened to have a right.
But didn't feel like a girl thing or whatever. Even though Anella is.
Man, you know what? You know what? I ain't even tripping.
Man's a Virgin. I say good. You know what I mean? If,
if you gonna be this mean to other people, then you know, whatever you get,
I'm just not gonna feel that bad for you. You ain't. Yeah.
I'll hope be stay safe, go in nowhere.
You ain't going nowhere. It's like, you can't be stopped now.
Cause you Virgin for life. Now listen, listen, iron need the affect.
Like I wouldn't go out a, a, an ugly girl cause that's lowering my stairs.
What do you think? Every hot girl who get with you is doing, <laugh>
not going out with you. I mean, not only are you ugly in terms of your,
your physical looks but your personalities. Oh yeah. It's all is is,
is a zero out 10.
Why you ain't got no alibi Mo when Y you think you got that way, literally,
literally go mama, listen, this is what I'm gonna say. Okay.
You can either lower your standards or you can die alone. All right. All right.
So buy a dog, buy a cat, buy a lizard,
whatever it is that you want do collect li die alone, dive Virgin.
That's how it would be. I have 0, 0, 0 sympathy.
None for people who go into the dating world.
Mm-hmm <affirmative> have absolutely no successes because of the fact that
they're constantly chasing beautiful people.
And it's really just their behavior. That makes exactly that.
Put them in that predicament. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So if you have standards out too high and you can't get any success,
that's your fault. And I'm not gonna feel sympathy for you.
Don't expect it from me none.
And I'm pretty sure you're not gonna get it from most people.
So if you're out there and you keep going, ah,
I can't find any hot one below your standards. That's it. That's all I got. God.
And I hope you stay single until you rectify your ways.
Cuz whoever gets to be in a relationship with you,
that's gonna be a I'm terrified for yep. That's gonna be a big,
big outward Jesus freaking Christ. Yeah.
And the worst part is that you read the comments, you read the comments. Yeah.
But anyways, that's it for today's video. Let us know what you guys think.
Did you guys enjoy? And if you guys enjoyed today's video, leave a like comment,
subscribe, like good stuff. Right?
The.